medical mistakes are the third leading
cause of death in this country but if a
mistake happened to you or maybe someone
in your family would you know who to
call kirsten joyce shares insight from
one company that noticed a trend with
covid and medical malpractice claims
over the past two years our nation's
hospitals have been inundated delays and
disruptions in medical care a
consequence of overcrowded and
short-staffed hospitals strapped with
covent patients and others seeking
treatment victor bornstein noticed a
certain trend about a month and a half
after the spikes
that we see in hospitalization there is
a spike in medical practice claims it's
his business to notice as he's the ceo
of just point a company created from a
personal experience when he was seven
his mother suffered a medical mistake
she received the wrong injection and was
in a coma for two weeks a very
complicated time for us he started just
point to help people going through tough
times when it comes to personal injury
get quality representation and maximize
their payout whenever they have to find
an attorney and it's very difficult to
know which attorney to go for so we use
data to find the best attorney for each
person the company says its database of
more than 300 thousand claims from court
systems in the u.s enables it to match
people with the best law firms last year
the company saw a 25 percent increase in
medical malpractice claims being filed
nationwide kirstjen joyce live local now